every Bank in the Sudanese Capital
Khartoum is closed people who
desperately need cash to buy food and
other Essentials are unable to withdraw
their money I mean since Saturday all
banks have been closed there's no water
or electricity the people are suffering
I'm a security guard I'm feeling the
brand due to the absence of security
across the Nile River in the city of
onderman almost every shop is shuttered
the few that are still open are running
low on supplies
we haven't been able to procure any good
since Saturday I'm selling out of the
stock in my shop and Warehouse if it
runs out I have no alternative but to
wait patiently until the dust settles
the price of food has spiked in the last
week people worry about how they'll
survive if the fighting between the Army
and the paramilitary group the rapid
support forces continues for much longer
honestly speaking prices are very high
we cannot drive around to get what we
need we call them both parties to sit
and reach an understanding otherwise our
country will collapse
conflict that is out of control
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
Carl schembry is the regional media
advisor for East Africa and Yemen the
Norwegian Refugee Council he says people
are resorting to Desperate Measures to
escape the conflict
I've had colleagues in the east in
gadaraf meeting thousands of people who
left from the capital and what the what
the madani some 160 kilometers southeast
of the capital people have walked all
that way to to flee to safety they're
exhausted they're tired looking for safe
areas around the country like like what
madani which are thankfully away from
the fighting that's that's the
experience of many and so done right now
a lot are are going towards Port Sudan
trying to evacuate from there but in the
meantime many are internally displaced
looking for shelter in camps and in
reception areas that are being set up by
the local authorities and and local
volunteers the UN have reported over 20
000 who fled to Chad already a few
thousands gone to South Sudan Egypt and
Ethiopia the the real numbers are are
still hard to come by even of internally
displaced people the figures keep
changing as together with the Dynamics
of the fighting wherever it gets harder
and and hotter people are fleeing if
they can or or if they've been also
locked inside their houses uh trying to
to stay safe but that in itself is also
deadly because people are have run out
of supplies water food and no
electricity
for the last 10 days now